joining us right now fresh off
dominating another olympics
katie ledecky joins the show the
three-time olympian the seven-time gold
medalist congratulations katie on
another
incredible run in tokyo my first
question do you
check the metals do you fly with them
carry on how do the metals get back home
yeah hi ben um yeah i flew with them and
my
in my carry-on they're they're safe and
sound and um
still still looking as good as when i
got them we talk a lot around the nfl
when these guys get their super bowl
rings of where they wear their rings
if they're just going to whole foods
picking up some groceries now let me
just pull out the super bowl ring
where do you wear gold medals
uh well i do keep them nearby the the
first couple weeks and months because a
lot of people do
do like to see them um i i wouldn't say
i take them to the grocery store on a
regular basis
but hey you know sometimes sometimes
there's somebody there that wants to see
it so
i'll bring it by katie ledecky joins the
show she's partnered with bic
razors for the game on campaign which is
about the importance of having
self-confidence and
katie what big takeaway from this
olympics of course is i think for the
rest
of us civilians we've finally been let
into
the thought process of what it means to
be a professional athlete and the impact
that has
on your confidence and on your
self-esteem so talk to me a little bit
about
this issue that's facing not only your
sport the olympics but just
sports and humanity in general the idea
of taking care of our mental health
yeah i think you know what i'll say is
i'm so grateful for the opportunity that
represented team usa and i'm
really proud of all my team team usa
teammates for
what they've done on the field in the
pool in the gym
but also what they've done off of it and
while the medals and the records
that i've achieved at this this
competition are
a validation for all the hard work that
i've put in over the
past several years my my primary goal
was
was to leave tokyo having inspired
others and
that's really been at the heart of my
partnership with with vic and
and big soleil razors uh we want to
inspire people to be confident when
they're
they're chasing their dreams then not be
afraid to show it um
and i'm uh really happy with with how my
my meat went in tokyo and i'm really
happy with with all the experiences i
had and
i felt like i was was confident behind
the blocks and and felt really good
about
each one of my races and i hope that all
of my teammates and i inspired
a lot of a lot of swimmers out there a
lot of young kids to dream big and
not be afraid to work really hard to
achieve big things
whether that's in the pool or out of the
pool or in some other sport or
in school or whatever it is that that
you're passionate about
because i think if you you have some big
goals you have some confidence
and you believe in yourself you can do
some big things
katie ledecky joins the show seven-time
gold medalist three-time olympian ben
lion's in for rich the rich eisen show
katie when tj jefferson wins one week of
fantasy football
he's on one all week he's celebrating
popping popping bottles he wins week
five
we don't see him till thursday what do
you do to celebrate
what's the turn up like now that you're
home
hey you know i i've had my share of
fancy football experiences like that as
well
um but you know it's um it's
i'm just trying to relax and enjoy this
and enjoy being with my family and
friends
being being reunited with with my family
and friends um
coming off these games and um just just
trying to let it all sink in
after the rio games i took a very short
two or three week break and i was
back at it with with my goals for tokyo
and
i do have my eyes set on on paris in
2024 and i know that i'll be
be back in the pool pretty soon uh
working hard for that but uh for right
now i'm
i'm really going to take a breather
enjoy being with my family and friends
and let it all soak in let's just take a
moment now round of applause
for it again because that was something
everybody in here was curious about the
idea of
is she gonna get back in the pool and
try and make another run out yeah katie
and you kind of gave michelle tafoya
some side eye when she suggested that
maybe
this was your last olympics when did you
make that decision and when are you
gonna start training again for paris
no you know i mean it was it was a
totally valid question and
i love michelle and i feel bad if uh
anyone thought that i
um had a reaction to that question at
all because
um no i've always had my my eyes set on
on paris and i think i've been pretty
clear about that
over the past several years and um i
i don't have my goals yet for paris all
i know is i want to be there and i want
to compete for team usa
and in the next several months i'll
start getting into the weeds in terms of
deciding what events i want to target
what kinds of times i want to achieve
um what kinds of metals i might want to
earn those kinds of things
but for right now i'm i'm keeping my
mind off of that as best i can
it's a little a little hard because yes
you do you do get asked that
um right after after the races from
anyone and everyone so um i know it's
gonna start becoming more and more of a
focus for me
over the next several months but for
right now as i said i'm still
still letting tokyo 2021 sink in
in addition to winning a ton of olympic
medals you mentioned that you've won
some weeks in fantasy football so katie
i'm very curious about your fantasy
approach
do you work the waiver wire do you try
and make a blockbuster trade
how do you construct your roster for
fantasy
you know i've been playing fantasy
football um with my
cousins for a while now and uh
some people are a little more serious
than others and i joke with my mom i
think
we're the two that probably do the most
adding and dropping of players
and some of my cousins who don't do
anything end up winning
more games than than we do so i think my
strategy going into this fall
is probably just gonna be to to be hands
off as much as possible and maybe even
have some uh
some some spots empty on my starting
roster like some of my cousins
do some weeks and see if that went
hey hey katie this is tj i want to say
congratulations
um and since i'm putting together a rich
eisen show fantasy football league i
would love to extend and invite to you
to play in our league what do you think
i mean you don't have to be here we're
pretty lacks
but you know we do expect you to put a
starting lineup in every every week so
um
the invite's there it's all i'm saying
okay
yeah i maybe created some some trouble
for myself
[Laughter]
got all sorts of invitations now well
this is what happens when you win a
bunch of meadows you get all types of
pitches and people want to do business
or they want to invite you in their
fantasy footballs
it's more so that we could say we have a
gold medalist yeah
in our league so it's it's more for us
than it is for you katie just to be
honest but we'd love to have you there
you uh you talked about inspiring the
next generation of swimmers or just
folks out there who are looking for that
inspiration
and you look at the performances that
not only you had out there
in tokyo but your teammates uh the
entire united states
swimming program the men and the women
what do you think
uh is the impact of going out there on
the olympic stage how have you seen that
inspiration be received in your own life
it's been awesome and i i had so much
fun with with my teammates
we were together for the four or five
weeks in between
olympic trials and and the olympics and
just had so much fun together and
it's it's more than the medals and the
records it's those memories
and and those times that you spend with
your teammates that i
i walk away with at least and and uh
really will remember
for a really long time uh just the
reaction by different swimmers when they
have the performance of a lifetime or uh
just all of them
all the emotions and all the hard work
that goes into it uh it's so fun to see
everyone perform on that stage
and um i already missed my teammates
it's only been a couple days where we've
been
away from each other but i i really miss
them um it's so much fun
and uh it's really such an honor to
represent team usa on that level
katie ledecky joins the show she's
partnered with bic razors after the
olympics on their game on campaign ben
lyons in for rich on the rich eisen show
we've got this idea as civilians uh when
we watch the olympic athletes compete
and i know the olympic village is
different this year but we have this
idea in our head
that you guys are kind of milling about
running into each other and so
if you're getting ready for a big race
and you want to grab a bite to eat do
you just run into carly lloyd trying to
get a sandwich
did you just run into devin booker
looking to get some ice for his room
what's the vibe like in the olympic
village
well i i don't think the women's soccer
team or the men's basketball team
were staying in the village this summer
but yeah it
really is like that um i mean the some
of the men's basketball players i think
came over
on the day of opening ceremony to the
village because i did get a picture with
kevin durant
and saw him and a few of his teammates
um
and i know that there were a number of
other big names
in the village um and you just see
athletes from all different sports all
different countries smelling around as
you said
just so many different body types um you
know you
you spot the the really tall players
and you're like all right they're
volleyball or basketball
there are some cyclists that are doing
their training in the village so you
have to watch out when you're crossing
the street because
you might just get run over by a biker
going
you know 50 miles an hour or whatever
they're going
um and there's speed walkers that are
doing their training around the village
and that's quite a sight to see
um so yeah it's pretty amazing and i
think
i was surprised at how similar this
olympics felt
to the two that i had experienced before
this
i mean of course everyone was wearing
masks and there were so many protocols
in place
but it really did feel like that
that village had the same energy that it
did in london and
and in rio when i went to my first two
olympics
incredible stuff congratulations katie
we're so excited for you i know tj is
really hoping that you'll join the
fantasy football league but for the rest
of us
we're just happy that you're gonna give
it another shot to get back in the pool
for the next olympics in paris
congratulations thanks for spending some
time
thanks katie yeah thanks so much katie
ledecky joining the show
partnering with bick razors for the game
on campaign inspiring people with
self-confidence you know what it takes
to get out there on that olympic stage
to go out there and compete with the
whole world watching
it's incredible it's incredible hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here